hi I'm shadi ash night we recently
changed the name of the team to sound
and vision I think it sounds a bit
better than the image processing because
we grew so much out of just image
processing I've been giving these series
of what's new in image and audio talks
for the past three four years but
honestly there is so much happening in
these domains that it's hard to show all
of them in one half-an-hour talk there
are so many other talks some of them
have happened some of them are happening
today a lot of them are happening after
this I'll give pointers so that you make
sure if you're interested in the topic
you do go to the other talks as well I'm
gonna in this talk I'm gonna show a
little bit of audio because I wasn't
sure all of you have made it to previous
talk which Pioche gave on import/export
of audio and the another one that is
later this afternoon at 3:30 on
processing and analysis so I'll show a
little bit of that it's still the
introduction we we are putting it in our
talks mainly to show you what's coming
and mainly to get feedback that's always
one of the very important aspect of tech
conference so that we put up content
that is on their development to get
feedback so please while you're still
around we are still around give us
feedback there's been tremendous updates
on audio and image analysis a lot of
focus on machine learning neural net
integration and applications that are
possible with the combination we have
had some special focuses like speech and
speaker analysis in the audio side face
and textual image understanding in the
image side once those are wrapped up
there are other application domains that
we're gonna go into while working on
those talking about how do we embed
findings from images audio and now video
into those objects to use them later has
brought up this idea of annotations for
different objects in the image for some
of you have been in the discussions
livestream design reviews and so forth
you may have heard of it
it's it's not a clear path for us at
this point where we're going what we're
doing another point that I put it up
there but it's not really a feature we
are featuring we are hiding it as much
as we can as developers but any feedback
is going to be useful so that we can
finalize those designs and really know
or get to the point that what's going to
be useful to have let's start with the
most exciting thing which is the video
which combines so many frames of images
that we have handled since version 7 and
audio which we start at handling since
version 11 we are expanding the number
of formats that we are supporting so
that with the old functionality of
import and export that you could get
video frames frame by frame and metadata
and so forth you can now get it for many
more formats and as Pierce was just
showing next door there are a lot of
codecs that we are supporting ffmpeg is
the back end we're also utilizing
operating systems on mac and windows
both so we are really trying to support
many file formats and many codecs a lot
of them that you can now import and
process in Mathematica the default
player on your operating system may
choke on playing so we're hoping we're
going to be the hub that can really
handle any type of video codec and then
as well similar to these variables that
are coming dollar video decoders dollar
there are there is dollar video encoders
for export and there is also all you end
subtitles decoders and expects encoders
which is giving you the full scope of
things that are going to be supported on
your platform on your machine because
it's going to be platform dependent so
video is a new head there is going to be
an object that contains all of this
information image data audio data and
metadata in one place the player that we
are showing at this conference is just a
prototype this is a cue the minute and a
half
video that Steven didn't click the play
on at the keynote and pure try thing
didn't have time to show it I can just
pause and show it it's a cute thing ends
at the end nice let me see the GUI still
hope
[Music]
so why the pool thing tries to cross the
road the video object is all out of four
so we don't really care how large is the
resolution of each frame or how long the
video object is it can live happily in a
notebook and play the GUI is not as
smooth as we would like it to be now
because all the data is being imported
into the caramel and sent back to the
front end to be displayed and so for
that matter high resolution videos and
high frame rate will be laggy so if you
release this in 12:1 know that this is
laggy but we know it's like it's not
going to say like that we're working
with the front end team to have proper
library links support in the front end
this is driving the library link support
front end the library link support in
the front end there is going to be a lot
of other applications of library link in
the front end that is not a benefit
[Music]
okay that thing didn't die the first
thing I asked the author when he showed
me that video is that is it gonna
survive after a minute and a half he
said yes anyways the head of this object
is video this is now common paradigm
from the objects that we have introduced
there is a video cue which returns true
if everything is alright information is
gonna return some information like how
many tracks of video how many tracks of
audio how many tracks of subtitle we are
currently supporting any video with any
number of those any number of tracks for
any of those three which is complicating
import/export a little bit so you have
to actually know which track you want to
access if it's a single track thing it
might be annoying Pierce was just
talking about that next door feedback on
that would be valuable for us at this
point similarly to audio stream if you
have played with that we have a video
stream I really don't need to show that
player again unless you want to see the
thing again video stream is an object
that is basically a handle to a specific
position of the video object at a given
time so I can create dynamic of position
and current image and then call video
play again very similar to audio play
this is a dynamic of Karen frame that
audio plays through the sound card and
the position is changing as we go
not to bore you with the same thing
again my daughter's wouldn't mind seeing
it again so so that's a way of
programmatically starts stop change
position in time and get other
properties from it we believe it's gonna
be useful this is the back end for our
for our GUI and then these stream
objects are going to enable you or any
user to create create whatever GUI they
would like to create there is some
minimal analysis coming into a1
obviously more is plan this is something
similar to what Steven showed as well at
the keynote video map is one of the
functions that get a single frame at a
time runs any image operation on it
returns the result as one sample in the
time series so a time series comes back
this is a single value per frame we get
a single valued plot this other one is
okay this videoblog map is another
analysis function which gets a buffer of
images at a time returns one result so
in this point I'm getting two frames
moving the buffer by one frame computing
image distance on those two frames which
is basically giving me how different
telling me how different one frame is
from the next one the plot that I'm
getting that Peaks are basically saying
that at some points in time basically
the scene changed or something
significant happen in the video so
that's kind of a scene change and you
can't imagine any tracking algorithm or
anything that requires more than one
frame at a time is going to be handled
through that other than just getting
frames in and returning some analysis
back we can also get frames in process
them put them back so that two functions
that we currently have improved I builds
that we are developing our video apply
and video filter video apply is a single
image in single image out so in this
case I'm just running a color negate the
result is basically a negated version of
that video frame by frame
good for Halloween
I suppose sorry yeah looks like a new
video and then obviously for us to be
able to have those processing
capabilities we need to we needed to
have export to make all of this happen
now that export of video is not useful
otherwise anyways there's some new
formats that are being supported by
export and obviously again a whole lot
of encoders on top of that what we are
getting which is not specifically video
processing or video analysis is all of
them in epilate exports and other types
of exports to video hopefully it's going
to be coming with or without sound again
pure just showed that next door just in
case you miss that and here I have a
manipulate and then I'm exporting it oh
I didn't plan to run any of that I just
already have those Oh
oh yeah I killed that one sorry this is
another one that I'm exporting and
manipulate mmm
with an audio let me check okay let me
see this is something I generated sorry
was just in a different location so I
exported the manipulate weather sound
object or an audio object at the same
time to a new video file from
Mathematica so I just changed that
directory it's gonna work so as I said
here to talk about import/export before
this recording should be available Chen
you and I are talking more about video
and basically showing a few more of the
application examples that we could put
together for now to show what may be
possible in the future any feedback on
any of that would be greatly very
valuable audio updates there has been as
I said a great push for having neural
nets and machine learning tight
integration with all of the other
applications that we have we when we
least 12 we thought it's justifiable to
have separate product pages for machine
learning for audio and images I didn't
repeat these examples in the talk but a
very typical application example is that
you have a specific set of audio samples
or in the case of image image samples
that you would like to classify there
are not the notable people that we
already have a built-in classifier they
are not types of objects that we have
classified image identify for there
might be things like animal sounds that
you just happen to have a data set for
anyone to classify them so these
examples are I think great starters for
anyone who wants to see what is possible
to be done with our system using all the
great machine learning capabilities that
we have in and all the built-in audio
processing capabilities that we have
this example goes you know grabs a bunch
of samples of different types of animals
and then runs a classifier and it's
doing a fine job so for any types of all
your sample that you have these are the
kinds of example that you would like to
get small but important audio wasn't
supported in the cloud for various
reasons it took us longer than it should
have but if you were upset with the fact
that all you weren't playing in the
cloud it does now since a couple of
months ago so small but important there
are some audio streaming updates coming
I'm not showing any examples because
they weren't both working in my build
but the importance of the first one that
I have there we're introducing infinite
generators for audio streams via this
same audio stream construct that we have
had before but we just feed it a
function that can infinitely generate
samples for a streaming audio infinitely
I think this is a good practice for us
to next look at podcast live streams of
audio maybe live stream of video we were
talking about IP cameras earlier in this
conference so all of those are practices
that we are step-by-step trying to build
into the system and see where we're
going next another idea that is cooking
is collection of these things how do we
want collections of audio to
and be treated in our system basically
if you have a list you want them to
synchronously play at the same time in
parallel do you want them to be a
sequence of audio that you play one
after each other and then if you want to
seek from in a collection of audio
samples how do you jump from one sample
to the next or how do you jump to 10th
minute of that collection of audio
regardless of how many they are and how
long each one of them are so these two
are basically as I said just practices
that we're doing to see what kinds of
applications these are going to enable I
don't know combining combining it
generated stream with an existing file
streaming it eventually out to the world
exporting them so there are just so many
things so many ideas that are cooking
any feedback is greatly valuable on
those as well audio stream can currently
generate finite audio from a time series
and that was already released in 11 2 or
3 I think that's there but anything else
that is not we are interested in knowing
what are the things what are the needs
out there what what kind of connection
we can discuss maybe after right right
the argument of that function is going
to be time if the generation process
takes longer we haven't played with that
yet good practice can be record
generated stream Carlo yeah and can't
can that wait for the for the samples to
ok but I think it would be a good
practice for us to add utilities for the
process to either wait or have some
default values to fill in or something
like that I guess all of those are
viable solutions there is a whole talk
about speech this is I'm not gonna spoil
the next talk that Carl and Rebecca are
giving just just a quick snippet because
I know this is a lot of talks going on
so I'm not sure if everybody's gonna
make it to the next talk speech
recognized was a valuable addition on
top of that we expanded or combined
speech recognition with interpreter and
text cases so here I have a sample that
said one this was not very loud if I run
speech interpreter on that audio sample
for a class like semantics number I get
the recognition I get the interpretation
of that speech signal back in the system
so you can imagine this is gonna be very
useful for spoken forms so that you you
hit on the microphone you record
something quick and then interpretation
of that comes back this is another
recording of a date next I have to
increase them so this said next Tuesday
I think this is an interpreter problem
in the recent bills that we have Italy
Italy let's see if interpreter can
interpret that so similar to that we
combined so we have a good phrase you
use prototype latest prototype nightly
prototype ills you get everything but
then you do get everything including new
york is the most popular city in the
united states of america so this is a
recording and we ask for speech cases
that are warts so we get that back then
you can this is the same recording I
believe if I don't play that again we
get cities and countries back I don't
run the interpreter again for this one
notable speaker classifier is coming
similar to notable person classifier I
just go a bit faster so that I don't run
out of time but this is this is nice and
easy
speaker feature extraction is
be useful to doing any speaker analysis
again Carlo is showing it right after
this or in half an hour after this I
this is I think I'm just gonna run out
of time I can try let's see this is
getting a bunch of samples from resource
data well maybe not that bad the the
samples look like a recording like that
they have a speaker ID and then they
have the ground truth of what that class
is instead of trying to classify for the
numbers for the digits to do the actual
digit classification we are using this
network which is basically trying to
separate speakers not the spoken word
not the numbers the speaker and the
output of that net is basically a
feature vector like that if I space plot
the feature space plot all of the
vectors that I get back for the samples
from that spoken digit dataset instead
of getting a bunch of ones and twos and
threes and fours I'm supposed to get
back a bunch of speakers which are they
know that by these unique IDs attached
to each speaker and you can see that
each speaker is clustered into a
separate location again more of this is
coming in the next talk more in depth
more details make sure if you're
interested in that you don't miss it
speech synthesis very quickly we are
trying to hook up to services so that
higher quality speech synthesis is
coming hopefully next release and then s
SML is a symbolic representation of
speech we are looking into that as well
a lot of updates for image processing
again a quick jump to the product page
that we created a lot of very practical
hands-on application like this one which
is using the image identification that's
to classify something else that is
unseen to our system before there are a
lot of little utilities I always like to
talk about them because this is
development time and it's valuable image
assemble was one very simple function
for instance this is just a sample of
all the things which couldn't handle
assembly
a bunch of images that had different
properties like different sizes here we
put some minimal development time into
trying to make this kind of a thing
possible so that you don't have to worry
about what's the size what are the color
color spaces what are the bit depths and
things like that of images and then one
you know fairly useful application of
things like that is that you do some
kind of a processing on an image and you
want to show it and a grid for instance
in this case it's just becoming easier
so a lot of what Steven calls LCC and
ILD is really happening the language
consistency and incremental development
is happening in all corner of the
language and other fairly important one
spatial transforms everything speed is
becoming important for us especially
with upcoming video so something is
simple like that where we're doing a
transformation wasn't fast enough so we
put some development time into improving
speed of that so it's again just a
sample of so many of similar kinds of
developments that we are doing which is
not necessarily highlighted in our
releases but eventually becomes very
important so this is an example Marcus
showed a couple of years back which is
getting a bunch of points on on an image
and doing a thin plate spline transform
it wasn't as responsive this is live
transform you just get some control
points and move them around as fast as
quick it's it's easy to miss them in
their releases but they are all very
valuable very important highlight images
updating instead of red it's returning
magenta highlights now which is
important because when you had a lot of
times it was confused with the pink
boxing we got we got that feedback
enough but more than the color change
and there are labeling and ledge ending
that are coming which is also lines up
with the annotation problems that we are
trying to solve when you have labeled
regions that you would like to highlight
it it would be nice and they were
working on making that even better to
have the labels in place or have them on
the side as a legend
or have them both image toolbar has been
there for a while I don't show this just
skip it we are we're thinking about
doing updates including making some kind
of an interactive annotation potentially
if that becomes a real thing
specifically as I said we focused on
facial and textual image analysis in the
recent releases we had face detection
before we are adding face alignment
which is very crucial for any face
recognition application that's coming
and then just to highlight the fact that
highlighting is important that these are
approximate ages for the faces that were
detected it is nice to have them all in
one place text analysis has been there
for a while it still has a lot of room
for improvement one new thing that is
coming is fake text detection which as
well is going to be discussed next in
their talk by Julia and Mikhail so you
now can get bounding boxes rotated or
not on images that have text this is
going to work for natural as well as
scanned images like that and then you
can you can split the words that are
detected by character word lines and so
forth all good utilities that have very
broad range of applications there is a
MOOC coming up for image processing this
is my thing is gonna get released in the
next week or two it's a basic course but
it's I think a very good entry point for
anyone who is missed a image processing
class or never touch the topics but one
wants to step in and learn about it so I
thought I would mention that in case you
have anyone who may have interest
annotations we had released audio
annotations in I think 12 but we really
kept it quiet maybe one example in the
product page I have a second left so I
just I just show the kinds of things for
instance in this example we annotated
all the loud parts of a signal and we
have a way of displaying it sticks to
the audio object when it comes to export
there is not really a good container
then maybe putting it in an XML file
next to the audio file and similar
things are gonna be coming for image
annotations okay so similar bounding
boxes of objects that we have detected
or ages corresponding to people detected
you know all of those I think would be
nice to store next to the image as long
as the images in our system but then
when it comes to exporting and typically
no formatted nicely supports any of that
a lot of import/export updates in the
image all your domain to make sure
things are robust and as fast as
possible the high efficiency format has
been a request for a while that's coming
DICOM DICOM dear for those in medical
fields has been requested and a lot of
more efficiency updates again they have
been talks on specifically on
import/export but as well on library'
link utilities which is a product of our
development in our team because we rely
on a low level libraries and we rely on
efficiency so watch out for that as well
which is being released on github
hopefully soon thanks
[Applause]